Washington is way too secret heavy they
classify everything they possibly can
because they don't want to have to
answer for whatever they don't have they
don't have to deal with with dealing
with the press or whatever
the the majority of classified documents
and this is just a guess but I I imagine
the majority of classified documents are
not actually going to if if they were to
be if the information were to get out
it's not going to put the us at risk the
majority I think they just classify way
too much I'm just saying it's it's it's
the the the the the clock people came
out today because they knew that there's
nothing going on yeah they're like we
have our shot in the video I think I
think more fun to guess
who We're not gonna find classified
documents with you know what I mean like
I think Michelle Obama's gonna be fine
kamala's gonna be good there's no
there's no Michelle Obama's in trouble
they're gonna find classified documents
with her because they trust her with
things but Kamala Harris they were like
you you can you stay over there